what really happened to albert wesker
are the ashford twins more than an
easter egg does chief irons know more
than he's letting on all that and more
right here spoilers ahead
the resident evil film saga gets a
reboot with 2021's resident evil welcome
to raccoon city skewing more closely to
capcom's original video games than the
previous film series this new spin on
the umbrella corporation's ghastly
experiments with bio-organic weapons
takes players back to the beginning
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
opens with the brother-sister duo of
chris and claire redfield as children in
the raccoon city orphanage claire is
visited by lisa trevor a tragic monster
whose backstory is unexplored in this
movie unlike in the 2002 remake of the
original resident evil however lisa is
not a raging monster but a scared little
girl who despite her ghastly visage only
wants to be claire's friend the true
villain of the intro and indeed the
whole film is dr william birkin who uses
the orphanage as a source of fresh meat
for testing his viral concoctions as in
resident evil 2 birkin is shot by an
agent looking to secure a sample of the
g-virus he survives by injecting himself
with the experimental serum and
transforming into a monster his first
form is taken down by chris and claire's
well-placed shotgun slugs and a
point-blank handgun headshot like any
classic resident evil final boss however
he returns in an even more mutated state
he nearly kills the redfield siblings
before leon shows up with a rocket
launcher and takes him out for good with
a missile to the face this is most
definitely a nod to the video games
where this kind of thing happens all the
time having a rocket launcher appear in
the film's climax is a true gift to fans
of the games you figured out the one
thing i wanted more than anything else
in the entire world and you got it for
me and
it's perfect one of the biggest
divergences from the games in resident
evil welcome to raccoon city comes in
the form of the leader of the doomed
stars team sent to investigate the
spencer mansion what's his name oh yeah
albert wesker in the game wesker is a
double agent who has been working for
the umbrella corporation all along
helping to create their bio-organic
weapons and basically causing all kinds
of problems and being a jerk to the
heroes
you guys are idiots
in the movie he has no loyalty to
umbrella yet he still betrays his team
this time it's out of financial
desperation and a desire to leave
raccoon city a corporate town that would
be seen as dying even if the entire
population wasn't turning into
flesh-eating zombies he's given a palm
pilot with a map of the mansion and
instructions to retrieve a sample of the
g-virus this puts him on a crash course
with dr william birkin which doesn't end
well for either of them
as in resident evil 2 resident evil
welcome to raccoon city ends with the
heroes and young sherry birkin on an
umbrella cargo train leaving the city
but in the original resident evil they
escaped via helicopter thanks to stars
pilot brad vickers who rescues them from
the roof of the mansion after throwing
down the rocket launcher they use to
defeat the first tyrant brad vickers
does show up in the movie but he doesn't
make it past the mansion he's ambushed
by zombies flies his helicopter into the
mansion and dies in a massive explosion
that nearly kills jill and wesker
between the train escape and what was
almost a helicopter rescue welcome to
raccoon city manages to nod to both of
the games that inspired it
whether we're talking about the original
games or paul w s anderson's films the
fate of raccoon city is always bleak in
resident evil 3 the city is wiped off
the map by a missile strike which
contains the outbreak at a terrible cost
in resident evil welcome to raccoon city
the destruction of raccoon city is
portrayed somewhat differently rather
than a tactical strike from outside the
city limits raccoon city is essentially
made to self-destruct through an
underground detonation apparently
umbrella has had the entire city rigged
to implode in the event of an outbreak
as a fail-safe system to contain any
prospective infection while some fans
might be upset to see this different
version of raccoon city's destruction
it's worth noting that resident evil
apocalypse while often ridiculed by
gamers does feature a faithful
recreation of the missile strike shown
in resident evil 3 so sure it makes
sense for the new movie to try something
different
after resident evil welcome to raccoon
city ends a brief scene interrupts the
credits showing the return of albert
wesker no he didn't survive being shot
to death by jill valentine he's being
revived by the mysterious benefactor who
ordered him to steal umbrella's secrets
this person reveals herself to be none
other than ada wong the fan favorite spy
who made her debut appearance in
resident evil 2. she explains that she
brought wesker back to life and hands
him a pair of sunglasses in the games
wesker is almost never seen without his
iconic sunglasses he's the rex kramer of
the video game world all right steve
let's face a few facts
the post-credits scene works as
something of an origin story for this
new take on one of the most popular
villains in video game history it's also
worth noting that this wesker and ada
occupy roles that are the opposite of
the ones they hold in the games there
aydah works for wesker during the
raccoon city incident as shown in the
death store scenario of 2007's resident
evil the umbrella chronicles by the time
the events of 2005's resident evil 4
roll around aydah is ostensibly aligned
with wesker but secretly working with a
still unknown employer in resident evil
welcome to raccoon city wesker is
basically a regular cop ada introduces
to a new world of espionage and
intrigue in the wake of raccoon city's
destruction william birkin's death and
albert wesker's resurrection unanswered
questions emerge firstly does lisa
trevor survive in the game she's nigh
invincible only dying for good when the
mansion explodes around her be a good
girl and stay dead this time
in the film she shows off her physical
strength when she tears a liquor apart
in physical combat thus she and her
video game counterpart clearly have
physical traits in common much of her
game-bound backstory doesn't appear in
the film however will fans learn more in
a subsequent film secondly who is ada
wong working for in both the games and
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
ada wong is a mysterious agent with a
penchant for spy games
i was just some pawn to you
look i'm just doing my job it's a sure
bet she'll play a key role in a sequel
if the box office fates allow it
thirdly how much does chief irons know
about umbrella in the games brian irons
the rpd's chief of police is an outright
villain who murders the mayor's daughter
and nearly kills sherry burkin in the
movie he seems to know about umbrella's
dastardly deeds but he's not a villain
in fact he even brings claire and leon
to the raccoon city orphanage and tells
them how to get to spencer mansion
before getting attacked and killed by a
liquor he's likely in on umbrella's plot
to some degree but whether or not that
qualifies him as an outright bad guy is
open to debate
traditionally each game in the resident
evil saga tells its own story set within
a wider interconnected world sometimes
characters and storylines are dropped
for years before being picked up again
for example sherry birkin from 1998's
resident evil 2 doesn't make another
proper canonical appearance until 2012's
resident evil 6 where she appears as one
of the main playable characters the
point is with characters coming in and
out of the games all the time a film
sequel could conceivably go anywhere in
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
the story wraps up in a reasonably
airtight fashion meaning the filmmakers
have their options open when it comes to
how to approach a sequel teasing the
ashford twins might be more than just an
easter egg a second movie could adapt
portions of 2000's resident evil code
veronica which takes chris and claire to
an antarctic base where they fight the
ashfords and a powered up wesker in the
game's canon jill's next key appearance
following the destruction of raccoon
city occurs in resident evil 5 where she
is brainwashed by wesker to fight
against her old allies still resisting
at such an advanced stage
leon next appears in the beloved
resident evil 4 though it's totally
different from the prior games it
wouldn't be surprising to see some
variation of that entry's leon and spain
premise form the basis of a future
resident evil movie finally while the
umbrella corporation is the main
antagonist of the film and most resident
evil projects it's mostly absent from
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
however the film's ending suggests they
will continue to be the villains of
future projects if so oswell spencer the
founder of umbrella who is mentioned by
name in the film will likely make an
appearance as he has a close
relationship with albert wesker in the
games this new film series could do
something interesting with their
particular dynamic
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]